okay okay it's it's a boy it's your baby
boy psychobabble with tons of there and
ready to play this block inning game and
wake up a chance hey right now oh it's
based on player choice like whether I
eat chicken or not the consequences of
all your in connection with students
will impact the past present and future
choose wisely oh [ __ ] I never choose
wisely all right great good got the
light nightlight it's just this is bad
this is just
I've been habit
what's happening
think about it so that when you know
contraption you start how did I get here
and where is here
we there's the White House always save
it like you make it dear not good I hope
please let me make it there
ok
okay okay I get it I got it it's it's
wet you know other things just went the
other way I'm so bad it's like yeah like
wait [ __ ] you Mike this is returning to
the disaster area here we go shadow
you're confusing i [ __ ] wow that was
I tablets in there Tim let know what the
acad 19
[ __ ] man
the graphics in here pocket not so
language man no matter how many tampons
that ain't gonna stop that baby here
don't have our
I'm gonna stop that
how sad okay
wow wow just kidding that was so surreal
the classroom little pieces of time but
he could be talking about photography as
he likely was okay i'm in class
everything's cool I am okay from light
to shadow from color to Kira skier oh oh
now oh can you give me an example rocks
of yours eyes her likely captured the
human condition in me didn't fall asleep
and that sure didn't feel like a dream
Bueller weird Diane Arbus there you go
Victoria yr vez because of her images of
hopeless faces you feel like totally
haunted by the eyes of those sad mothers
and children she saw humanity is
tortured right and ideas and frankly
it's bullish it should keep that to
yourself seriously though I could frame
any one of you in a dark corner and
capture you in a moment of desperation
and any one of you could do that to me
why can't I isn't that too easy drag
cards and release what if Arbus chose to
capture people with the height of their
blood innocence look at this crap how
can I show this to mr. Jefferson I can
hear the class laughing at me now it's
just pretty good that she had a
brilliant I so she could have taken
another approach I have to admit I'm not
a big fan of her work I'm not gonna tell
yourself it's robert frank me to Victor
I can't believe I still have his pencil
case I should upgrade to the 21st
century and it was honest but yeah I
like it old school year I haven't kept
up with my journal as much as I should
you don't have beauty without a beat
which explains why I do love my analog
camera I should take a quick picture now
but uh that's kind of [ __ ] up I have
all seen that iconic shot of Kerouac on
the balcony and if you haven't shame
shame kapsch I believe max has taken
what you kids call a selfie a dumb word
for a wonderful photographic tradition
and max
has a gift of course as you all know the
photo portrait has been popular since
the early 1800s your generation was not
the first to use images for selfie
expression sorry I couldn't resist the
commands that the portraiture has always
been a vital aspect of art and
photography for as long as it's been
around now max since you've captured our
interest and clearly want to join the
conversation can you please tell us the
name of the process that gave birth to
the first self-portraits the carrot
types you're asking me let me think mmm
you either know this or not max oh I
know is there anybody here who knows
their stuff Louis Daguerre was a French
painter who created dig area types a
process the give portraits a sharp
reflective style like a mirror now
you're totally stuck in the retro zone
sad face what if she lets go Victoria
the de garyun process brought out fine
detail in people's faces making them
extremely popular from these [ __ ]
the first American to garyo types of
torture lot done by Robert Cornelius oh
it you can find out all about them in
your textbook my little camera bag is
battered but still kicking hey guys
don't forget the deadline to submit a
photo in the everyday heroes contest
i'll fly out with the winner to san
francisco where you'll be feted by the
art world it's great exposure and it can
kick start a career in photography so
Stella and Alyssa get it together Taylor
don't hide I'm still waiting for your
entry to and yes max I see you
pretending not to see me oh what a
[ __ ] catch he has got a tampon up his
hassle that it's blocking his flow that
is all I could say that tablet I'm gonna
use her tablet and I should have known
she'll have better equipment than
blackwell hey Pat no thank no thank you
I should smash that [ __ ] I should smash
it and [ __ ] in selah cool books are
doing if it's broken yeah I can't
believe she made fun of me in class what
is she 15 years old
uh-huh okay laughed hi Kate oh I just
find Maxie everyday heroes isn't
important to you soon you seem quiet
today just thinking too much I got it I
hear that want to go grab a cup of tea
and [ __ ] about lights thanks but not
today so I have to go over homework no
worries let's hang later okay sure I'm
so popular sometimes I just want to jump
off a cliff looks like somebody was
already working on this cool shut the
[ __ ] up whoever was working out I
[ __ ] spent on let's see how this
[ __ ] has etched marks amber yeah yeah
let her got this [ __ ]
I will spit in that lady's mouth mr.
jeffris said hello hello excuse me mr.
Jefferson can I talk to you for a moment
yes excuse you know Victoria excuse us
I'd never let one of photography's
future stars avoid handing in her
picture hands a 10 do I have to I just
don't think it's that big a deal max
you're a better photographer than a liar
now I know it's a drag to hear some old
dude like sure you but life won't wait
for you to play catch-up you're young
the world is yours blah blah blah right
but you do have a gift you have the
fever to take images to frame the world
only the way you envisioned it mr.
Hanson or that jess us all you need is
the courage to share your gift with
others that's what separates the artist
from the amateur oh and the camera
quality important yeah like look at
camera very nice i like the art style ok
otic steel no sorry whoa mr. Jefferson
is not messing around with that monster
I like a hassle probably paid 20 grand
for that camera I bet he gets pristine
digital images peg says dig my instant
can't Ave and I like I'm really handsome
look it's sushi looks like every time I
look at Victoria I believe she's talking
smack about me she has chance I here's
the tire is it door open you didn't tell
me how cute islands yet I was about to
mapping you all into the real world cute
huh
then I might send you a special students
making out oh she plays it so sure I
need a serious timeout in the bathroom
gut gut flush water around my face and
make sure I don't look like a total
loser JD pretty cold head Oh score Ian X
God God God she's a [ __ ] shot good
hello hello hello Justin hello then oh
my god to all of you Alec American girls
it said to imagine a world
jus
it looks like she's been gone for 19
years old before I can arrest Regina was
she that was one that's forever
by the seaside watching the world
I love beautiful Juliet God
join the chest table missing poster
Rachel [ __ ]
right nobody can see I melt down except
for me oh yes yes I can cash it at any
time I want I can go in the corner and
just like [ __ ] on the floor if I want to
do that's how I can I am Rachel amber is
a [ __ ] that is so [ __ ] up she's
[ __ ] us and we've bothered to write
that crap um the Keller mirror ok you
see I could get in there that God good
good I'd like to use this I feel like
the universe is taunting me everywhere I
go today it all started with that
bizarro dream in class am I going crazy
I like to use this um I'd like to clean
my face oh god oh my pores their clan
just relax stop torturing yourself you
have a gift hey I don't [ __ ] it no you
[ __ ] [ __ ] yeah yeah yeah oh wow
when the door closes a window opens my
god an hour that can okay girl you don't
get a photo up like this every day get
it get it get it I'm gonna photograph
this batch yeah yeah yeah he's a hero
finally metamorphosize my deck into the
man I wish I was oh [ __ ] like who's that
stretch
he's like oh [ __ ] i'm in the girls
bathroom cuz i want to share school name
is don't stress you sure you're okay bro
just count to three I need help you own
this school I wanted I could blow it up
you're the boss okay what do you want oh
[ __ ] I hope you check the perimeter is
my step ass would say now let's talk
bidness I got nothing for you wrong you
got hella cash that's my family not me
Oh boohoo poor little rich kid I know
you've been pumping drugs and [ __ ] two
kids around here I bet you're
respectable family would help me out if
I went to them man I can see the
headlines now okay yeah them out of this
[ __ ] I can tell everybody Nathan
Prescott is a punk ass who begs like a
little girl and talks to himself you
don't know who the [ __ ] I am or who
you're messing around with her did you
get that what are you doing this is kind
of [ __ ] I'm gonna stay down ever tell me
what to do I'm so sick of people trying
to control me you are going to get in
hella more trouble for this than drugs
nobody would ever even miss your punk
ass would they hit that gun away she's
head of your class ok ok ok is that kind
of gonna hit the ground I shudder
of course not oh my god punishing that
good good what the [ __ ] how how can that
be I was in the bathroom he shot that
poor girl I held up my hand thank God
and then I was back here I catch it
Sorry Sorry ideas of time oh I already
heard this lecture from light to shadow
from color now Kate is being hassled
again Oh Therese fealty got hit by the
rock again this is real now can you give
me an example of a big dog you not
believe this absurd the human condition
in black and white okay if I'm crazy I
might as well go all the way bueller
diet and I actually reverse time ago
Victoria yr vez uh yeah get good let me
suck that up let me suck it up
come on uh uh uh yeah can you guys see
Leah did it photographer who perfectly
count you mean time machine way anybody
Thanks don't freak out not yet I'm gonna
take that savia be honest because of her
images of hopeless face when who took my
selfie Jefferson asked me a question if
he does again I'm nurses for real kids
call a selfie dummy a dancer we're on
tradition and max has a gift I know I'm
not dreaming this you all know it's real
richard has been pop I can tell the
early 1800s your generator I can go back
in time just for self-expression what if
that girl isn't dead yet good misses the
point can i say yes always been a vital
aspect of art and photography for you to
go to the bathroom quickly and check it
out now max since you've captured our
interest and clearly want to join the
conversation can you please tell us the
name of the process yes to the first
self-portraits it's um I use the
bathroom I'm sorry but I really have to
use the bathroom nice try max but you're
not gonna get away then we can talk more
after class oh no anybody Jefferson
wants to keep me after class and I need
time to save the girls a process to give
portraits a sharp reflective style like
a mirror oh sorry you're totally stuck
in the Metrozone sad face who's that
sound of Victorian what if I were
winding it
I'm the radio sir okay come on now max
since you've captured our interest and
clearly want to join the conversation
can you please tell us the name of the
process the gave birth to the first
self-portraits yes it's it's a dick
Aryan process everyone knows that
vegetarian process invented by a French
painter named Louis Daguerre around 1830
somebody has been reading as well as
posing nice work max very good the two
Gary I was just making sure shamefully
ha there I wish as engage way that
cleared if I doesn't affect her makeup
but you so you can learn more when you
actually finish reading the assigned
chapters max is so far way ahead of ever
hey guys don't forget the deadline to
submit a photo in the everyday heroes
contest i'll fly out with the winner to
san francisco where you'll be feted by
the art world it's great exposure and it
can kick-start a career in photography
so Stella and Alyssa get it together
Taylor don't hide I'm still waiting for
your entry to and yes max I see you
pretending not to see uh what i could do
is photo got that person not great
eyeing you manage win the contest it's
time to be in everyday hero I am it
everyday hero [ __ ] okay you still have
to do your home speak even if you're
submitting your photo for the
competition everybody in class is
starting to excuse me mr. Jefferson can
I talk to you for a moment yes excuse
you no secret sucker might excuse us I'd
never let one of photography's future
stars avoid am NOT avoiding I'm not
avoiding just biding time waiting for
the elusive right moment exactly max
don't wait too long John Lennon once
said that life is what happens while
you're busy making other plans mm okay I
don't meet if I if that's okay don't let
me stop
I'm press control even if you're
submitting your photo for the
competition everybody in class I see you
max Caulfield don't even think about
leaving here until we talk about your
injury oh dude we talked about it anyway
I think I thought you're gonna talk
about this I never let one of
photography I'm on top of it I think
John Lennon once said that life is what
happens while you're busy making other
plans all right max you're on fire today
all the right answers good make sure you
finish working on it by today I have
faith in you this guy's gonna do they
get in love with it I it's kind of
creepy I'm gonna walk away I'm a contest
okay oh sorry I kind of open this I hope
I have enough time to get to the
bathroom please please I can't tell
anybody don't think i'm crazy i'm
holding shaft of a fast ass huh
you know I don't eat I hate that science
class with those peers what's that got
to do with anything okay max retrace
every step I washed my face i shredded
my photo how's that matter then the
butterfly flew in and I took a photo why
don't you just equate in the stall so
they don't talk there leave them out of
this [ __ ] I can tell everybody Nathan
Prescott is a punk ass who begs like a
little girl and talks to himself you
don't know who the [ __ ] I am oh who
you're messing around where did you get
that what are you doing come on put that
knee down tell me what to do wowser it's
happening you can meet a hammer to break
it open hello much chef this the drugs
nobody would ever even if your punk ass
one day okay oh [ __ ] I can't let this
happen if I can reverse time again I can
help her miss your punk ass one day get
that gun away from me psycho oh god they
are wait [ __ ] down don't ever touch me
again free
spit on him spit on him Oh Jase less she
missed the perfect opportunity to spit
on him another shitty day
that did not happen this cannot be real
I just saw a girl gets shot and then
saved her what the [ __ ] is going on the
language on this girl freaked out hey do
you hear that fire alarm that means you
should be outside I had to use the
bathroom girls always use that excuse oh
excuse for what for whatever you're up
to your face is covering deal the alarm
tripped me out then trip on out of here
Missy or you hiding something huh Thank
You mr. Madsen the situation is under
control there's no emergency housing no
miss call face oh and please turn off
that alarm I think that's your job he
better cut the ship before the [ __ ] cuts
his tired you know pinches it early I
hate pension actually now let's not sure
some days I just feel like pinching the
turd as it comes out like dicing it up
like carrots you know uh uh hello Sal
like the fake to you a little stressed
out are you okay I'm I'm just a little
worried about my future you're sweating
pinballs is that all you're thinking
about you could always be upfront with
me max you face it's like well I have
you done something wrong is that it
that's a very well nice way to make
yourself properly uh I'm gonna report
Nathan and kill him I just saw Nathan
Prescott waving a gun around in the
girls room Nathan Prescott you sure yes
he was in the bathroom talking to
himself with a son that girl was okay
trouble was babbling like crazy okay
slow down slow down so now you saw this
without him seeing you I was hiding
behind a stall I have the right to be
there it's the girls room I know I know
I just want to be completely clear what
happened hi mr. Prescott happens to be
from the town's most distinguished
family and one of Blackwell's most
honored students so Todd for me to see
him brandishing a weapon in the girls
bathroom
so what happened next then then he left
I ran out you're wondering what to do
are you gonna bust him this is serious
charge I'll look into the matter
personally thank you for bringing it to
my attention that's it after what I told
you'll continue this discussion later in
my office please go outside with the
rest of your class now Miss course I can
ass huh of course this academic drone
won't do anything since the Prescott
family owns blackwell now I should I
don't mind didn't change my story no
[ __ ] yeah [ __ ] and I tell the guys can
I shared someone alright let's just let
him be enjoyable huh what the heck hello
Blackwell Academy all of them yes so
much like take in his
with Nathan Prescott please come to the
front office thank you okay good uh
hello I like the sick day I miss grant
excuse me max I know everybody loves
being asked to sign a petition but would
you do miss grant a favor and hear me
out God sure sure I always have time for
you what's the petition David Madsen our
chief of security wants to put
surveillance cameras all around the
campus halls classrooms Jim dorm rooms
etc okay good Blackwell Academy should
be a high school not a high security
penitentiary
yeah I guess cameras could have helped
Rachel I can see both sides you're fair
minded max and we all pray rachel has
found safe and sound bless her soul but
this petition isn't about that check
Blackwell Academy has a noble heritage
from the Native Americans who found this
man to the pioneers who shared it he's
not fear and violence the Native
Americans the tribes who were here first
who welcomed the settlers both cultures
found a mutual symbiosis and thrived now
before I assign you homework with this
lecture will you please sign the
petition to keep our campus from going
back to nineteen eighty-four no miss
grant I totally respect your passion and
knowledge but some security cameras make
me feel a little safer I'm not against
security max we should all be concerned
when private space becomes public your
generation has been tricked to think
everything should be recorded hey shut
it shut I will spit on our grave okay
because I'm definitely gonna however a
tap journal what the [ __ ] there's so
much [ __ ] going on
holy [ __ ] okay Hannah up what today tell
us happen
mr. handsome over there okay I better
get to my dorm and grab that flash drive
should I spent on her yeah she's having
fun you know there's no reason to spit
on her how is that ran uh-huh that's an
at4 that's fine hey Evan mind if I check
out your cool portfolio let's see if
you're worthy of it max you'll have to
answer a simple question who
photographed the famous falling soldier
and not kappa mm-hmm Jane Smith gotta be
eugene Smith well they both were famous
war photographer images but you should
know the difference good try wrong
answer yeah if I can match
and hey Evan mind if I check out your
cool portfolio let's see if you're
worthy of it max you'll have to answer a
simple question who photographed the
famous fallen soldier and that Kappa
uh-huh isn't it Robert Dornan oh my you
can't even difference between
stratigraphy and photojournalism no
portfolio peak for you I've all spent on
his [ __ ] forehead if he says um no
again I don't think it's kind of a is it
hey Evan let's see if you're worth stima
card course steve mccurry unless he
could travel back in time curry was born
five years oh so it's like the one I was
this her mom to call her in other words
no portfolio what a [ __ ] dick hole he
has way too much putting in his deck jay
says p.m. achieve your I'm [ __ ]
worthy of its Robert camp I don't
[ __ ] know that you [ __ ] [ __ ]
robert capa get ready for my deck I love
his work despite the controversy about
that photo my my this quiet child knows
things that's why I'm here [ __ ]
you're a kindred spirit max and how soft
you care for a perusal of my portfolio
yes I'd love to partner what a privilege
I grant too many I'd be honored oh my
god let me just say something okay you
know when people take like tobacco and
put it in between their lips and these
are girls are green put my [ __ ] in
between his wingman Rachel Amber's face
is mesmerizing okay
Wow nice [ __ ] [ __ ] hate that [ __ ]
let me see what the actions are uh hello
sorry Kofi a boy tech club sucks Luke
hello sorry uh hello max I don't feel
like talking no that's right what's
wrong Nathan Prescott little rich [ __ ]
kid he thinks he can own people like his
parents on black well like he owns the
vortex Club yes he's a nasty piece of
work you you know him all right not
really I've seen him not taking the
credit sounds like you know way more
than that max tell me no it's just the
deck nope he's just an entitled dick
with a lot of money not my type somebody
needs to take that prick down um nothing
else that's out he'll take himself down
yeah history always proves that right
just wait for justice you sheeple what a
[ __ ] dick hall okay look clever
seems an interesting actions that can
affect the game uh-huh dan yeah i'm here
to talk with you what's up Daniel oh hi
max could I am asked you a question what
is a [ __ ] you're lying I'm getting was
it you I do put my sketches on facebook
though uh yeah sure I'd be honored
Daniel makes me feel like a muse funny
you should say that I was just thinking
about my real boobs Rachel amber watch
is [ __ ] missing you knew her no but
once she asked me to draw her portrait
oh she was a natural what happened to
her so what happened to her there's got
to be a story she just stopped coming to
class some people said she ran away some
say she jumped off a cliff I just hope
she's okay
okay why don't you start drawing me even
though I must be a step down from Rachel
no way you're a good substitute news
yeah we would started but okay I have to
fill me with [ __ ] Jesus that's a
good posture
good wrist action good worst action good
good talk dad got good I got God God God
God oh very portrait ever you know I
like when you say good posture impose
but you don't even get lipo but that's
all right you know like some people
don't get it a lot contact man says I'd
be on face scrub you know hello punks
you want some [ __ ] around my fav part
haha jassen yo Justin check out the max
come to thrash I ass oh yeah bring it
what's your first move gonna be uh jump
you're such a poser if you can't even
name a simple no slider or trade plant
should walk on I hear daddy I can't to
know slide I came to know slide but i'd
love to see somebody do a tre flip ho
sik you're not a poser nah I just can't
skate work shed ha sagem house we're
gonna destroy some rails for you what do
you want to see ya know slide that's
seemed right just so ya know slide let's
get Trevor all over that actually it's
gonna pick em ready did ya fascinating
okay still the spike and then ever get
caught reverse now okay yeah this girl
is so weird hello man hello hi Brooke
let me guess you want to fly my drone no
go [ __ ] yourself I'd love to I love
planes and balloons and this is neither
do you know what a drone really is 0
weapon right uh you read too many
conspiracies all right this might be too
complicated for you honey Warren said
you were smart please step back what a
[ __ ] match hi Brooke let me guess
I'd love to this is neither Oh weapon no
you what oh honey look at our brag me
just searching that what a complicated
name for such a tiny drone she gonna get
me
hey Brooke let me guess
that looks like a high fly drum model be
400 evo now that's a nice piece of tech
you're full of surprises why would you
know that i love aerial photography
drones are perfect what a [ __ ] liar
great range oh it's a new era of it this
game is just like a seahawks warren said
you were multifaceted hair give the
drone world around campus
pretty crazy huh I hear they're pretty
like slower like because you'd like
press button and wait for it's like
reactor knife Alanis is [ __ ] leaving
oh you're very fun okay well it's time
to move on oh no I is this i talked to
hating rover last one hey Hayden sure
she is the retro selfie master that's me
all right you look relaxed as usual
Hayden it's a skill one cultivates at
blackwell especially when one represents
the Lord that song is the war tech club
not the most what the hell is the vortex
Club anyway it seems so elitist only if
you're not cool enough to get in and it
doesn't hurt your resume if you say so I
do but you should actually come hang
with us one night then you wouldn't be
so inclined to gossip and I don't think
so I don't think so I'm not miss party
that's because you haven't partied with
us or even Victoria it was very funny
when she's baked is it weird to think
about partying with all those Rachel
amber posters up your hi Rachel used to
hang out with us too she was a blast
smart not [ __ ] like you know
do you really want Nathan Prescott to
represent oh please nathan is like
everybody's voodoo doll that's sure he's
all right and a fun guy to hang with
[ __ ] the haters since I say oh that he
seems genuinely unstable to me Nate has
his extreme moments but don't we all I
don't know yet Hayden uh this is getting
pretty bad out here hi max no I have to
get my chemical on and study we should
get you and Dana out one night oh okay
and is this [ __ ] okay okay no thanks
the game like really want you to see
that I'll ask I'll ok ok oh alright so
that's the first part i think i'm gonna
add it right here because i'm probably
gonna do pretty fair out arrow play
through this so so the fact look like a
thousand years
thank you watch it yomo ventures